Even the White House says
it does not know the current
whereabouts of the man
who led last week's short
lived rebellion in Russia
and Ukraine's military intelligence chief
says that Russia's FSB,
the successor agency to the KGB,
is plotting to kill Yevgeny Prigozhin,
quoting him now from an interview.
Quote,
We are aware that the FSB was charged
for the task to assassinate him.
Will they be successful in doing that?
We'll see what time.
We're joined
now by CNN national security
analyst Steve Hall,
a former CIA chief of Russia operations.
Steve, I mean,
how likely is it
that the FSB knows
exactly where Prigozhin is
and if they wanted to kill him?
How hard would it be for them to do it?
Yeah, I would say that
this analytical statement by the
by the Ukrainian military
intelligence is not a huge stretch.
It's not it's not a particularly bad
analytical position.
If I were a betting man,
I think, for
instance, significant trouble,
you know,
threats from the FSB to begin with.
You know, the FSB is extremely good.
They'll be able to find him.
They know how to kill people.
We've seen that many times before.
For me, the big question is, why now?
I mean this.
If they were going to kill them,
the time to have done
it would have been
before he caused
all of the difficulties
that he has caused.
And of course, the FSB is the
are the ones who are responsible.
It's the organization that is responsible
for informing the president
in this case, Putin
and those close to him
that something is amiss.
And either they did that
and he ignored it
unlikely or they failed to to see it.
And so yeah, it's kind of obvious
now that they would want
to get rid of them.
But why not two or three weeks ago,
they would have saved themselves
a lot of trouble had they done it.
That what's
keeping Prigozhin alive,
if he is still alive,
we haven't seen the guy.
Yeah. This is another thing.
Is this that we just don't know?
You know,
what's good is so little information
right now.
And of course, this is what the Russian
one of the things
the Russians are really good
at is putting question marks
above these guys.
So percussion, you know,
the rumor is well,
everybody's saying that he's you know
you know, happy and healthy.
Maybe not so happy,
but he's in Belarus someplace.
Thanks to the intervention
of President Lukashenko,
we haven't seen the sort of weekend
either.
Another guy who
there's a lot of question marks over.
In a sense, though, this plays
into what I think
the Kremlin is trying to do, which is,
you know, if they do the expected it,
they go ahead and kill these guys.
Then everybody's like,
okay, well, that's predictable.
And now that's over.
And we're past that
by keeping some questions out there.
I think it keeps people
that Putin is still unsure about on edge
and perhaps
they will make a mistake,
which will then put them on the list
to be gotten rid of the well as well.
So there's some housekeeping that needs.
Yeah,
I was just going to ask
about keeping his internal house
in order.
Who are the people that Putin
is most concerned about now?
It's hard to say because of
the nature
of how difficult it is to predict
what's going on inside the Kremlin.
I think we all probably remember the days
when we were looking at
how many guys were on top of Lenin's tomb
when people were marching by.
And that gave us an idea
as to what was going on.
It's still very, very hard to know
what's going on inside the Kremlin.
But obviously the people
who have the most power
and who are closest to Putin
are the ones who ironically
are not only the ones
who would be called upon
to take care of problems,
but also the ones
who pose the greatest danger.
So the head of the FSB,
the head of the other security services,
even the senior military guys,
I think are at risk.
And yeah, he's got to do something
whether Putin does
whether or not it's a Stalin
like purge of everybody
or whether it's something more modulated
than that. We'll just have to see.
It is fascinating how history sometimes
seems to repeat itself.
Steve Hall, great to have you here.
I suspect we'll be talking soon
about some of this. I bet so.